whether or not on president is to shut
this president up right now because he
is undermining the doctors and the
scientists who are trying to help the
American people it is unacceptable to
him to be blabbering with unfactual
information I have to take care of those
who in fact are exposed or likely to be
exposed to the virus and that means we
have to do testing we have to get the
testing kits up and ready Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders finally went one-on-one
for the first time in the latest
democratic debate the faceoff moved to
Washington held without an audience due
to the corona virus outbreak
both men hammering the President as you
heard there on his handling of this
crisis as concern grows over primaries
set to take place tomorrow
Allison barber is live in Columbus Ohio
one of the states set to vote good
morning Allison good morning ed Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders are on the same
page when it comes to their criticisms
of President Trump and how he has
handled this crisis they offer different
solutions though when it comes to how
they would deal with it Joe Biden said
he would mobilize the US military right
now because they have the capacity to
build 500 bed hospitals to help with
potential shortages Sanders said he
would use the National Guard as they're
doing in New York this is like a war
we're in the middle of a national
emergency everything that you need in
terms of dealing with this crisis would
be free this corona virus a pandemic
exposes the incredible weakness and
dysfunctionality of our current
healthcare system and with all due
respect to medicare for all you have a
single-payer system in Italy it doesn't
work there
577 delegates are up for grabs tomorrow
in Arizona Florida Illinois and Ohio
Georgia and Louisiana decided to
postpone their upcoming elections the
four states voting tomorrow have said
they will proceed as planned
yesterday Ohio Secretary of State told
Fox News he doesn't see Ohio reversing
course and that the polls will open
tomorrow Tuesday at 6:30 a.m. election
officials say every Ohio polling
location will have the supplies and
instructions to follow hygienic
guidelines established by the state's
Department of Health as well as the CDC
there's hand sanitizer when people walk
into these locations to vote
hand sanitizer when they walk out we are
told pens and most voting machines will
be cleaned after every use still there
is concern all of that is not going to
be enough and as restaurants shut down
some believe voting polls should shut
down as well
could you guarantee to them that no poll
worker no voter is going to get sick by
showing up on Tuesday to cast their
ballots as we know in an issue like this
in a time that we're dealing with there
are no 100% what I can guarantee them is
this that their polling location the
people that work that polling location
are well-trained they have the equipment
the supplies to wipe down that that
location they've got the right
instructions as long as they follow them
from us if the voters are following
proper hand hygiene and that kind of
thing that it will be a safe and a
healthy experience there are some
mail-in voting options and also some
curbside voting options a lot of people
that we have seen in the last couple
days that seem to be taking advantage of
this state's fairly long early voting
period absolutely Alison Barbara thank
you